[Music]
all right let's go to
sarah in saratoga springs new york
what's up sarah how are you hi john how
are you
so good what's going on good um i have a
question for you
um last year in april um my husband and
i are
both 31 years old um last year in april
my husband almost died from an
undiagnosed heart condition
whoa um and we are
sort of a year out from that and my
husband is struggling with the lifestyle
changes that come with that
um so i just needed some advice to how
to help him through that
oh that's so hard sarah that's so hard
okay so tell me about what happened
yo just putting along and all of a
sudden whoa
um i was in my office one morning it was
early morning around seven o'clock
and i heard what sounded like snoring in
our bedroom so i thought because my
husband snores and i was like oh okay
but it was getting louder and i walked
in and
he couldn't breathe yeah suffocating
yeah
that's a terrifying sound when someone's
it was a congestive heart failure almost
uh
yeah his um when i was on the phone with
the
paramedics he actually um his heart
stopped
um and he like turned purple and his
face was like
you know not in a human form um
and he like stopped moving and then
um what i can only be described as a
miracle from god is
he like sat straight up and and
woke right back up wow um
[Music]
and they thought it might have been a
seizure but then they
figured out it was an issue with his
heart and he was in the cardiac icu
for two weeks and he had a
failed surgery that he almost died from
and then his heart stopped five other
times and they had to
jump him and they finally figured out
that it was a medication that he had
been put on
for depression that kicked he like he
had this heart problem
but the medication basically like kicked
it into gear
so he has an icd in him now to
help if anything else happens okay um
have you had
when you have to go through regular
checkups for that has there been any
has it caught anything or is everything
working fine now
seems to be working fine um his doctors
um told him he has to really change the
way he eats
and his drinking and smoking and all
that kind of stuff and they
they see him he has two cardiac doctors
and they see him every three months
okay so before we get to him before we
get to
you living with somebody who won't make
behavioral changes which is a
nightmare talking to you sarah
i know you're gonna do that hey listen
i've heard that
sound before and outside of the scream
of a young person
that is a sound that is like no other
it's that sound that sounds like snoring
but it's a
i've heard it called the death rattle it
is a very particular
noise that when you're with other um
emergency personnel
everybody kicks up because they know
what that means
that is a trauma for you have you worked
through this have you been
able to talk to somebody to experience
this or have you just been running full
tilt since this moment
i have talked to two different i've been
going to therapy since i was 14 so i've
been in consistent therapy
throughout it okay um and with one of my
therapists we worked through
like we did the thing of like what if he
had died and we like worked through that
of like
how would i be and stuff like that but
i've never
i guess that's the moment when it
happened
i've not heard of that therapy
yeah it was it it was that seems
almost as traumatizing wow
okay well whatever to each his own maybe
maybe one day i'll call your therapist
just to have a conversation that sounds
fascinating
it's like ah man in your desk near-death
experience
let's totally experience that right
yeah wow okay to each his own right um
yeah so here's the thing
so you know this you've been in therapy
i
less therapeutic more
you having a friend to sit with and just
be able to
weep openly you've been holding that
your body's probably been holding its
breath for a year
yes you are correct and i and i every
time i walk into the bedroom
yep every time you hear a sound yep
every time you walk out and you're doing
something and you hear a weird whatever
or in the middle of the night you wake
up and hear him snoring
and you reach out to put your hand on
his chest like
that is your body in fight or flight
okay
and until you let that cycle through
your body and you
completely go that was then and this is
now
yeah you are intentionally
not changing your behaviors okay that's
a mean way to put a trauma response
um but i just think a lot of us live
with trauma and we just assume that's
just the way that's gonna be and it's
not
but until you process that not by
imagining what happened if he just been
dead
that's a weird way to experience trauma
but
you gotta let the cycle run through okay
meaning there's gonna come a moment when
you're gonna have to reckon with those
feelings
the fact that you can't control whether
he stays alive or not
whether you can't control
whether you control very very little in
your life is basically what
handling that trauma response letting it
work itself all the way through and you
can finally exhale
you can finally sleep through the night
um
whatever that looks like for you i just
want to highly highly highly recommend
that for you
okay okay otherwise you're living an
electrified life
and that shortens your lifespan too yeah
right you can't fully sit in the joy you
can't fully
laugh all the way into your guts you
can't
fully enjoy sexual intimacy you can't
fully
get into life because your body is still
waiting for the other shoe to drop
right right
and as you can see i've heard that noise
and it sets me off
right and very few things sarah set me
off and that noise does
it's terrifying right wasn't saying no
no one's ever talked to me about the
noise
yes or like commiserated with me over
the noise and that's
and that's it like like if i hear
something that sounds like that noise i
like get out of my chair and i like go
around the corner
like my cat scratching on something but
like i think
something's happening and so your body
now has
to think of it as um
um an emergency response team and it
created a new unit
that all it does 24 7 365 is scan your
environment for sleep i mean for that
for that noise
and it will sleep less because it's
looking for that noise
and it will not pay attention to your
work and your writing and to the movie
and to sex and all those things because
it's scanning the environment for the
noise
until you can go in and process that
trauma and tell that
unit of your brain i'm good i'm good
so do i process that with a friend or
with a therapist or
both and that's everyone does it
differently some people take a journal
out to the mountains and they come back
all better
and some people um have to go through a
seeking safety program where they work
through the actual event
and relive it and they've got some way
they learn ways to
breathe through challenges so when those
when it shows up
how you can work through it and then you
become it becomes almost instantaneous
it's learning a new set of skills right
that's what it is um and
everybody does that differently but it's
you knowing i am consciously seeking
this
new set of skills so that when this
thing happens
i'm good and then i'm moving on yeah
right and then when you process that
then you're gonna have to deal with
you're going to be walk driving your car
someday
in the picture of him sitting up in bed
that terrifying look on his face
will flap flashback in your head and
then you're going to learn to control
your thoughts
and say nope i'm not choosing to focus
on that
and you're going to have some backup
thoughts that you go to directly
and then you're going to realize well i
can control my thoughts most of the time
i can't control the lightning bolts but
i can control
whether i meditate on that and let my
body set off on an entire fear response
based on something that's not going to
happen
again right and then you got to make
peace with
it can all happen again which leads to
the nightmare of living next to somebody
who's received a terminal behavior
change
who just won't change right right
meaning
if you don't stop doing x y and z you're
gonna die
and they go got it and they go home and
jump right back into x y or z
right so tell me about your side of that
um like like what he's doing or how i'm
dealing with it
both um well
he has definitely changed his diet
um and he lost 40 pounds
wow very cool doing yeah he's
he's very like healthy i would say in
his body but i notice when
stress comes up he goes back to his old
eating habits of like you know the
greasy stuff like all the stuff you
don't want to eat
i know but sarah listen cheeseburgers
make sadness go away for a minute it's
delicious
i know it just shoves all of my sad
feelings down right yes it does so good
and then after a while a few hours they
start coming back up
more cheeseburgers yes
awesome yep so um he's trading one thing
for another huh
yes okay um and then they told him
his doctor told him you can have a drink
at your 50th wedding anniversary you can
have a drink at your daughter's wedding
but other than that
you should never drink again and he i
would say he was like a pretty social
drinker
he was not an alcoholic by any means but
like he would have a couple of beers out
with friends he enjoyed a good whiskey
and it was very social for him yep
so the thought of not having that
he can't process and we
got to the year mark and we decided that
a year we would talk about it
and at a year i said you know i feel
comfortable with you having one drink or
two drinks a month
but i don't know if i'll be comfortable
with anything more than that
because the doctor said what's he
comfortable with
he is comfortable with what he
feels like is right so he won't tell me
he he says you know i'm not going to get
as drunk as i used to
but i also don't want to be stuck to one
or two drinks a month
so here's the nightmare that is all of
our lives
we fall head over heels in love with
somebody we get up in front of
our friends and family some rando pastor
somewhere
and our grandparents show up the ones
who are still alive
and if we're religious we get in front
of god and say
i'm right or die with this one
and then you go home and realize i can't
control them
then you got kids and it gets even worse
and so what i will tell you right now is
any sort of behavior change predicated
on that's balancing on
what you're going to allow for him will
not work
and that's heartbreaking
yeah and it's something tells me
that there's a
basically he's been told you got to
change your whole life your friends
your community the way you engage with
the world all has to be different
or you're going to be dead and
as his wife the person looking in that's
easy
fix it right because your decisions are
going to affect me
but there is an unconscious decision
when faced with
a major life change of change all of
your life
or be dead there is an unconscious
[Music]
i'll play the dead card i don't believe
it happens to other people
yeah that will deal with it later that's
a problem for you know future husband
it's not worth the immediacy of i need
to see my friends today
i miss a dark smokey room i-i-i which
means
when you're living out of a you can't do
these things
it's always a fail that's why
restrictive diets fail 100 of the time
they just fail
right right versus hey
me and you have to go create an entire
new universe what we're about
who we are more importantly where we're
going why we're going there
and what that picture is going to look
like
and you have to be as equal co-creator a
co-author a co-painter of that picture
as he
is as long as you're on the outside of
this thing
barking orders at him directing him then
it's it's a you become his mom and
nobody wants to
be married to their mom right and nobody
wants to be married to their son
it becomes hey we gotta just read the
whole thing
so you're there in new york the analogy
i use all the time usually it's when
infant
like after infidelity you may have heard
me say this on this show
you cannot take this is a before and
after moment just like the last caller
everything was okay until his heart said
i'm out right
till you heard the man of your of your
life
almost to be dead and you're in the bed
that you sleep in
okay and i'm being intentionally direct
here okay
yeah you you got to go back and look at
911 with the twin towers you could never
sweep up
all that glass and twisted steel and
metal and recreate those towers with
those same ingredients you can't
the only thing you can do is take two
years
excavate the whole thing clean it all
up completely wipe that slight clean
and then get some great architects build
something new
design and build something new and now
that new tower is strong
it's powerful it's beautiful it's a
monument to what was and it's a
arrow pointing to the future right
that's what you'll have to do
the last data i looked at and i think
this is back in 2013
it's been a while was faced with a
terminal
decision men adult men two out of seven
made the behavioral shift wow which is
dreadful numbers
so number one don't hold me to that data
that's the last i remembered
um and it could have shifted up by then
number two
that tells me that the behavior the this
or that
isn't the issue the issue is
the ecosystem the relationships the what
that means
that's what matters and
so what y'all have to do is the hard
work of saying all right we're starting
from square
square one square zero i mean except
we're already in it together and i'm
gonna heal
you're gonna heal but we gotta reinvent
this thing from the floor up
okay and here's where that really is a
risk for you sarah he could say i don't
want to
yeah he said that the other day
okay so what do you tell me about that
um i spoke to him about how i
was talking to my therapist about what
i'm comfortable with with
the drinking and stuff like that and he
said
you know i don't know if i'm willing to
do that and you're probably going to
leave me anyway because i don't think
i'm willing to do that
there you go and then later that night
he said you know we probably have a good
10 or 20 years left
but then you're gonna leave me and
here's what happened and again i'm not
blaming i'm walking alongside you
you promise you you give me that on that
okay oh of course yeah when it becomes a
i'm not comfortable with this that
creates a you versus me
okay that becomes a right side and a
wrong side
and him saying oh well i mean if you
drew a line yeah eventually i'm gonna
screw this up
and so and since it's you versus me
you're just gonna leave
and that's where an excavation process
is no we're doing this together this is
us
and so similar to the last caller what
you got to do is you got to take him out
somewhere
and say i set this whole dynamic up
wrong
i said i'm going to let you do some
behaviors
that i'm comfortable with and i said
that wrong and i shouldn't have drawn
that boundary between us
i should draw boundaries around us but
not between us
and so what i what we have to do
together
is reimagine tomorrow completely new
from the floor
that means we may have to get new
friends i don't think so i think though
our friends will make adjustments with
us
we may have to move towns we have to get
new jobs we may have to
look at everything from the floor up
because i'm not living my life without
you i don't want to
i want you in it not you can't you can't
and i don't know a lot of people that
walk away from that conversation because
that's different than
if you don't then i'm gonna that's
different then hey i'm in it
i'm in it ah a minute
and then you gotta hold on the other
side man that's a risk that you're
taking
because he can look at you and say hey
you know what i'm out i'm not i'm not
doing that
i'm out let's deal with that when we get
there
my guess is that's not going to happen
my guess is when he hears your heart
your willingness to
go with him and you all go to a new
therapist it's not making you do these
weird thought experiments about
pretending your husband's dead but that
is about
all right let's clear the deck and build
something incredible and new
we're going to paint pictures together
we're going to live into those things
man this is our moment to dream about
what we were going to do and what we
should have been doing but let's do it
now
let's move to kansas you don't have to
move to kansas
but whatever that's going to look like
now we're all in
you're stud sarah
he's lucky to have you and let's
back this thing up and start all over
again